je crois profondément en la
perfectibilité des êtres humains
on pourra enfin réaliser notre potentiel
si nous sommes au meilleur de nous mêmes
aucun problème ne peut nous résister on
peut guérir toutes les maladies ou
vaincre la faim dans le monde
imaginez ce que ça représente pour les
droits de l'homme
les possibilités sont infinies vous avez
réglé 20 dollars 86 et le montant de la
facture était de 20 68 c'est moi qui
vous remercie
[Musique]
point coup profite de la soirée et
surtout éclate toi tu es à ce cycle ça
va c'est jared qui va te former moi
aussi c'était dur les premières semaines
j'ai vraiment ramé crois moi tu dis si
tu devrais venir me voir au boulot de
temps en temps qui vont croire que j'ai
nettoyé des toilettes tu es vraiment
apprécié c'est une employée exemplaire
pas tout de suite eu une bonne moyenne
on ne voit jamais sur le campus le
week-end mon père à une crise c'est pour
ça que j'ai dû aller aider ma mère c'est
lié à sa sclérose en plaques
j'ai étudié de près l'assurance médicale
de tes parents et je crois que j'ai une
idée je me demandais si les parents mais
pourrait bénéficier notre mutuelle
je vais vous dire à quel point c'est
important que tu vous remercie d'avoir
aidé ma famille tu fais partie des
heures cale est tout ce qui compte pour
toi compte pour nous elle n'est ici que
depuis quelques mois mais elle a déjà
fait forte impression
tu penses que ta conduite et pire ou
meilleure quand tu sais quand tu
observes j'ai actuellement une dizaine
de personnes qui parcourt le monde avec
ses caméras
tous les deux avant d'aller à l'aventuré
on s'amuse et on découvre et des trucs
et toi tu étais audacieuse et
enthousiaste et maintenant tu vis tout à
travers un film
[Musique]
j'ai pas voté pour ça c'est parce que je
voulais
ce que fait the circle il faut que ça
s'arrête
les données de tous les membres de ce
recueil sont analysés monétiser
il pourra en faire ce qu'il voudra ont
été rares laboratoires
[Musique]
parce que savoir c'est bien
mais tout savoir c'est mieux
tu n'aurais pas quelque chose à nous
dire
the washing
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
un centre-tir que c'est sûr
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais un morceau qui tacle si jamais on
doit [__] le boxon
bon je vous explique j'ai novembre
prochaine de virtuoses du larcin est
bien sûr notre petit mozart du karting
le public raffole des histoires de
braquage de banque à leur cerveau lors
quelque chose d'éclatants et d'explosifs
art qu'elles pourront évoquer autour
d'un café latté qu'est ce qui ne coûte
attend on va voir tequila
y'a quoi de bananes et de tequila
[Musique]
on a déjà dit peut-être un petit veinard
paraison bebig
[Musique]
ça mérite un oscar cette ânerie
c'est sûr
désolé madame
[__]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
où
salut la compagnie pour devenir un as
wenger major une période d'essai ouvre
un entretien fais moi plaisir content de
toi d'être l'araignée sympa de quartier
maintenant fait profil bas c'est toi
spider man depuis youtube
tu peux appeler une armée d'araignée non
aide égale costumes riches et les
puissants comme star qu ils n'ont rien à
faire de nous le monde change les amis
il est temps qu'on change nous aussi
ces armes sont hyper dangereuse et côte
peter oublie ce monstre au volant il ya
des gens pour gérer ce genre de choses
le ferry pour les armes illégales et qui
a dit leur porte
vous l'avez loupé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
t'imagines si quelqu'un était mort
j'essayais d'être comme vous je veux que
tu sois meilleur je vais reprendre le
costume je suis plus rien sans lui si tu
n'es rien son ce costume c'est une le
mérite pas
j'ai pas assurée tu dois arrêter de
porter toute la misère du monde sont
très cool
je veux que les choses soient claires je
ferai tout ce qu'il faut pour protéger
les nerfs je sais qu'on se comprend
tout mais pas sur ma route
je te tuerais toi et tout s'est tu m
la camisole en cours
ce type est là quelque part va falloir
que je m'en occupe
[Musique]
surtout ne tente rien de stupide
c'est clair ouais
[Musique]
c est vrai qu à trouver quelque chose
claire
[Musique]
oh pardon
[Applaudissements]
je souhaite que d'arcy czapla se mettent
à pourrir
oh mon dieu je peux souhaiter tout ce
que je veux l'argent venait
non mais t'es sérieux va l'amour l'a
embrassée d'autres personnes ont eu
cette boîte avant toi elles sont toutes
mortes et tous les gens qu'elle savait
aussi quand la musique s'arrête le prix
du sang est payé c'est un démon il veut
quoi ton âme je souhaite
tu contrôle plus rien qui te contrôler
jamais arrivé il ya vraiment un problème
ça fait perdre pour longtemps
jason a wish fait un voeu au cinéma le
26 juillet on colle le temps c'est pas
le même je te parle pas de météo infos
que je te parle de deux heures
interminables que tu vas passer avec la
crème des cassos de son lycée
[Musique]
j'te pinta mer
allez tu es pas un looser tu y vas tu
lui parles elle a sorti tous les chocs
et tu viens souvent encore louis tous
les achats d'or à faire dans ma vie
ah ouais d'accord t'as un peu de béton
en fait ça ok c'est une blague
les deux ensembles à fermer l'oeil je
sais pas
il ya quelque chose de bizarre merci
c'est quoi tout ce que je vis j'ai déjà
vécu
oui les parents forment la paire mais là
je ne sais pas et chaque fois que je
mets langdell puis trois minutes
je reviens systématiquement au début de
la cote 1 92 et du coup bah je suis
bloqué ça c'est marrant ça c'est vrai
c'est pas très bon
il est collé à vie et investit les
salles sont toutes pourries 10e
on dit pourrit pas pourri que les salles
sont pour its qu'on accorde le sujet
avec sa mère s'appelle toutes les
communautés itinérant paix dit oui
[Musique]
il faut que je trouve une fin à cette
histoire de ray-ban idée du temps là
souvent non mais là j'ai rien là c'est
exactement ce que je craignais
mais non ils échouent pour 3 minutes de
dawa total le tuf et marcal où la ferme
ta gueule
c'est qui le patron
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pourri si les pizzas oui pour moi
[Musique]
mais non
tiens mon frère
quand tu y crois c'est un bon endroit
cette mission est simple et rapide à
jean valérian vous agirez sol je pense
qu'avec ma coéquipière entendu on se
dira
vous avez quasiment 20 minutes de retard
mais le temps passe vite quand on
s'amuse
[Musique]
bienvenue sur alpha
la cité des mille planète pendant des
centaines d'années toutes les espèces
ont partagé leurs connaissances
dès leur intelligence en a remis un vrai
paradis
c'est incroyable
plos one
après des siècles de paix de prospérité
une force inconnue de détruire tout ce
que nous avons créé agents valérian et
laureline vous avez moins de six heures
pour localiser la menace et l'éliminer
allez c'est parti
[Musique]
les verts entier est contre eux
nous voulons que tous les deux vous
soyez les gardiens de notre futur
tu es sûr de savoir ce que tu fous
[Musique]
avec combien de temps
notre destinée est entre vos mains
c'est moi qui lui ai appris ça
[Musique]
nous venons de subir une véritable
débâcle
nous irons jusqu'au bout jamais nous
un appel a été lancé on doit aller à
dunkerque
paré a largué les amarres qu'est ce que
vous faites vous vous rendez compte nous
on va on a le cap sur la guerre vous
serez utile monsieur c'est un des noms
il maman
la ligne
le mardi on va s'en aller allez on
descend
il faut qu'ils on voit d'autres
vaisseaux
chaque heure qui passe les week-ends du
terral
ils ont réquisitionné les pattes au
civil les maths ou si il nous faut des
destroyers
ou est ce qu'on aura à dunkerque
j'y retourne pas il a laissé mourir
vous êtes des plaisanciers d'entre eux
tu vas la royal navy pouvez rentrer chez
vous
on ne se dérange pas ça fiston on a un
boulot à faire j'irai pas
nous nous battrons sur les plages nous
nous battrons sur les pistes d'aviation
jamais nous nous rendrons
j
qu'est ce qu'ils foutent d'osaka peur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a fait
[Musique]
m
tf1
[Musique]
qui me dit on appris votre naissance à
toufflers et à toi ton père et moi avant
de divorcer
chacun puis un fils coût élevé d un côté
et évidemment j'ai eu la mauvaise pioche
j'ai un frère je bous
[Musique]
enfin je paie de ma connaissance
heligoland un témoin suis mal à l'aise
comment ça se passe pour toi au niveau
carrière
génial vous avez laissé le méchant le
plus recherché c'est sacré vous êtes
virer carrément génial ça dit gilles
j'étais fait venir pour reprendre
l'entreprise familiale
tu as la méchanceté dans le sang et
quelques années les c'est derrière moi
tout ça je comprends a coupé sa ville ce
truc
wola fâche bien méchant
pas mal du tout
[Musique]
alors vous avez fait quoi aujourd'hui
atrash toi
lien
au loin
[Musique]
salut
et ça ou quoi oh les filles ça fait
longtemps qu'on attend une fois j'en ai
vu une idée si tous je cru que j'allais
mourir
[Musique]
vous êtes des méchants maintenant